hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play condemned
criminal origins I got my shotgun even
though it has no shotgun shells it is
quite an effective detonating tool it
makes things dead very easily good flee
miss miss miss miss I'm great at talk
speaking yeah yeah how was I supposed to
know that was I supposed to just without
my mass spectrometer and find servers
get lonely to Bob hey what the hell
alright then crazy hi hi welcome to the
party
Oh yep Oh what that's it oh yeah oh that
oh god oh no my damn my my weapon
dabbling oh you broke my shotgun how
dare you how dare you there another
thing that I can use seems a bit more
deadly now chair stool anything
couch phone no okay oh wait where'd you
go I see you picked it up no ah
what up oh where do you come from ah hey
yeah wait each other that's cool I know
are you and my shotgun has disintegrated
for some reason all right so you
investigate waiting look yeah yeah
impatient no I had it it was right there
what did I but whatever maybe that's not
what I'm supposed to be looking at now
anything no this was it here I see it
it's right in front of my face oh man oh
I get it
oh no I don't get it what does idea III
get not it it's not get this I don't
understand
speak English miss okay so
ah okay I get it I need to follow it in
there which means I need to go around
bit bumpy boop boop boop up up up
what hey what done what the hell how why
what the um I was weird okay
sledgehammer call right after you oh
here we go Oh so strange goop on the
ground hi don't be like that
oh what's that [ __ ] what [ __ ] each other
well this guy looks angry Wow Oh got you
ah yeah oh so good
oh you so OD anyway any of them health
else I'm gonna be in trouble in a bit
here would be nice to have more than
just oh I see you I see you oh yeah oh
yeah
I'm gonna keep this legend because I bet
it has a lot of durability I wouldn't
laugh if for some reason somehow the
game logic is that the slash has the
sledgehammer can disintegrate huh
excessive
that's my middle ear what's that it I
couldn't have in it ah there shouts gun
again I'm very effective but you know
it's whatever huh okay
schwa leti strain white goop on the
floor hmm
it's so weird that it is that way that
it is follow the trend this couldn't
possibly lead anywhere bad fire axe what
goodness gracious all these requirements
just give me what I need and let me keep
it please I don't know where I'm gonna
find like you know wait what was that
where the trail ended oh it ended here
a collection tool
what am I looking at this
what is I are looking at what am I
supposed to be looking at what what
what tell me I want to know am I looking
at
ours service off I want to oh okay wait
no I get it oh that is what I'd be
arrows I just notice the arrows there it
is
ah III didn't notice the arrows on the
camera sorry I'm new this game better up
woman
Marshall Bret doesn't match anything but
it's not much to work with keep looking
well fine I guess I'm just not good
enough
I'm not good enough for that lady oh not
good enough for everybody
oh okay fire axe required there's got to
be a fire surrender someone who wants
shotgun
who wants many shotgun pellets to the
face let's put it that way
no nobody and oh yeah I can kick can i
oh I totally forgot that I can kick I'd
probably be much more effective wait a
min that the door that I was supposed to
in this the other side of the door that
what no I'm not jumping down there who
you fire axe like hell crap condo and oh
I will go down there in just a second
but for now I need to check make sure
that I saving checkpoint okay maybe I
will go down there maybe this is the way
forward then they gonna check this Han
ah what's that you startled me he was
coming right at me y'all sir
it was self-defense
huh Junko head off just like that ah got
it
Oh Jillian ugly what much Oh kick you in
the butt
oh oh how that'd be you but but what Ram
slap what well was that okay jump down
good yeah Oh like a mouse it's best dose
my favorite season I was down here
Oh who did that who was that
what that is [ __ ] us again ah ah oh
wow huh boo ah no ok whizzes slam oh
okay it's finishing moves huh that's
just the kind of cop I am when he's on
his knees and defenseless that's when I
hit him in the turnbuckle or through the
Grand Slam or the the folded burrito or
the um being interpret the masturbation
of mine okay that was like a waste of
time I don't even know why I went down
there anyway I'm not even gonna go back
punch the bird carcass behind a fire
door ow
I don't know oh no oh that's a lesson
train that simontann my salmon have fun
in nightmare land wait what what what
hey what hey hey hey hey
Oh what okay I got to go back well I see
phenomena I'm gonna trade out for that I
cuz I think that axe is shinier in gap
Brown
well my fist I didn't know that this cop
was such a master of the martial arts
hey that shotgun has a mammal in it but
I don't have time for that ain't nobody
got time for that
ah yeah doc who's detective me okay yeah
yeah okay I always feel maniacal
whenever I'm chopping down a door now
which way do I go here ah do I use this
on this no I was hoping oh wait no
elevator power box I'm an idiot
duh oh dear here ah so nice and bright
in here now
who's gonna be there huh we're gonna be
you're gonna look know that nobody wants
amazing we're good yeah
da da da da nobody nobody wants some
mess with me do things huh ha ha ha no
okay we're good moving forward hi that a
dead end or dying bird it is now what ah
let the bird wasn't dead yet
why did I pick up a live bird hey wait a
minute why that elevator go down hi
wow you strong whoever did that ah oh my
oh good golly
alright then
fine by me
marking on IG oh hey wait no this is
neither crowbar I don't have a crowbar
I'm not even gonna go get a crowbar cuz
I never am the right thing
I can't they make on all purpose your
head stop this who open that door
where's everyone oh there's a crowbar Oh
chop your head hey are you still alive
oh yeah Ram ah
wake up what that that seemed like a
good idea to do okay whatever let's go
open up that safe I'm getting a lot more
birds in this level than I did before
mostly good because they could have fall
right in my lap you guys pop up out of
nowhere
oh what's that a gun how many much
bullet for who keeps a gun and just puts
four bullets in it I mean uh uh I mean
really
that just seems silly I'm Tom Brokaw hey
he has a gun he has a shotgun no ow that
didn't her actually hurt very much
no aah
No Oh get ready for the pain that
pain this pain this pain to what uh i
can't blog Anna oh no don't die
oh don't die oh god oh man I uh bad I
gotta go find it
I think the huzzah yeah how am i
destroying a pistol either I'm so
terribly strong that was used it was a
medkit I think right here either I'm so
terribly strong that I just you know
absolutely destroy everyone I come
across or it's the opposite of what that
is seems about right
hello he's living for Althea
yeah Wow what done how did you rip the
door into the I don't even want to know
I don't even want to know I don't want
to know Oh bathrooms this seems good
I'll go in the women's first cuz I'm
classy like that Hey look a [ __ ] game I
bet this will be useful why is there a
hole in here some peeping holes so some
perverts can watch them women good about
that's just sick
it's disgusting huh oh it's a dead bird
in a toilet I don't want to pick it up I
don't want to okay
crunch you why kleptomaniac loser freak
weirdo Cup uh-oh my senses are my spidey
sense tinkling
yeah trail is very suspicious but I'm
gonna go in here first nope I lied
there was nothing in there my my
instincts limping the wrong way wait
what's that
ah what was this some guy down there
what happened I totally missed that all
I heard were loud noises well there's
more over here what what I just heard
loud noises
okay I'll be so strong got flesh hammer
now why did I need to follow that trail
I was weird anyway I'm all out of time
so thank you all so much watching click
on the annotation to see other stuff
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye